it's time for cruise news you're
overstuffed supersized good news hoagie
at the desk my trusty co-pilot ross
matthews hi everybody hi hi
and the intrepid host of inside edition
and our dear friend to the show deborah
norville
how crazy that we all picked blue today
i know it looks like we're all going to
prom together look at this we all
coordinate it's like an electric
cornflower and there's a bunch of other
ladies members guests over in this
section blue section over here who we
clearly got on a metaphorical telephone
with sent out a memo okay um deborah you
are a seasoned pro
um obviously you've done so many
hard-hitting investigations okay you are
the real deal journalist here
and we wanted to join some forces maybe
on some
crime stories great day let's do it okay
excellent um this is our first ever drew
crime inside edition special report
[Applause]
first of all i just have to say how
excited i am okay looking good cool
something i've never done in my life let
me try there's a first for everything
here we go first up the story everyone's
talking about the tinder swindler
millions have watched the netflix
documentary about a man who allegedly
conned his dates out of hundreds of
thousands of dollars but no one heard a
peep from the man behind it all but
deborah you have the scoop yes we do his
name is simon leviev inside edition got
an exclusive interview with him to hear
his side of the story
and here's what he has to say take a
look
you don't feel bad for them in any way i
feel bad for something that i didn't
done no i feel bad for whatever happened
to myself i want to clear my name i want
to say to the world this is not true
he says it's not true he denies all the
allegations but boy he seems to be
capitalizing on all the attention he's
partnered up with cameo where you can go
on the website and you'll get a greeting
from simon for 199 dollars a pop that's
if it's a personal one if it's a
business thing he charges more for that
he's working on a reality show he told
us he's working on a book
and his model girlfriend she says she's
going to stick with him
and it gets more interesting doesn't it
it certainly does this story is still
developing and the real diamond tycoon
family is reportedly suing simon now for
allegedly impersonating them and
unjustly enriching himself by using
their last name and we reached out to
simon's reps on this and they said simon
looks forward to sharing his side of the
story soon but this lawsuit that you
mentioned is really interesting because
the leviah family and they are huge in
the diamond business huge in the diamond
business now simon's name is not leviath
he changed his name legally to levi if
he started with a last name it started
with an h anyway the leviah family
followed this first lawsuit but they
have said that the subsequent lawsuits
will go after anyone who has enriched
themselves through their association
with simon from the tinder swindler
documentary so what they're trying to do
is
head off anybody from doing business
with this guy and protect their family
it's fascinating because there's still
more to report soon i can't believe you
got this scooter
and who knows what's next maybe he'll be
on dancing with the stars or something
like that oh you know he will be
[Music]